I'll be honest isuzu no-win scenario
this is a no-win review there's some
weird culture war going on online
between people who hate Captain Marvel
and people who hate the people who hate
Captain Marvel and like I don't give a
about any of it I feel like I'm on
a hilltop with my long hair popping
popcorn watching people fight going are
those interesting you know truth is
stranger than fiction I have no dog in
the fight I'm judging this movie as I
judge all movies did I like it did it
grab me did I like the characters it's
that simple so let's keep it that simple
and on with the review
[Music]
captain marvel so Captain Marvel is the
newest film in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it stars brie Larson as Captain
Marvel she's a Kree which pretty much
well they don't explain too much about
them the space police think Green
Lantern Corps without the Rings they
have guns that's how they came across in
the movie anyway they're hunting down
Scrolls which are aliens that
shape-shift into people then Captain
Marvel crashes on earth some Scrolls
crash on earth so she's on the hunt for
teams up with a younger Nick Fury cuz
it's the mid-90s so let's unravel us
pull it the threads of adventure Olive
Branch what I liked about this movie
first of all ben mendelsohn he's the
main Skrull I might be saying this
because I'm a Ben Mendelsohn fan I was
professor he's one of those actors were
even if he's in a shitty movie he's
still the great part in the shitty movie
I like Ben Mendelsohn is the head scroll
I actually liked the scrolls in general
by the end of this movie I dug them and
Nick Fury samuel l.jackson I didn't
expect him to have this much screen time
this is like a buddy cop movie a buddy
space cop movie or a buddy space cop
meets buddy agent 20s I love samuel
l.jackson i love him as Nick Fury and I
loved him in this movie and when the
movie started like the first act I like
brie Larson there's Captain Marvel
jerkily had some personality she's
talking a little bit of when she's
sparring with Jude Law I like that I was
like where was this in the trailers if
the trailers had shown this it would
have been way better then the movie goes
on it's like the longer captain Marvel's
on Earth's like earth is personality
kryptonite she still has a couple of
moments here and there every one with
this little girl I was alright that's
sweet I like that because that's what
the movie is movies is made for little
girls to be like I want to be like
Captain Marvel and the winks and nods I
the movie relies really heavily on winks
and nods it's like hey look at this
nostalgic stuff hey you recognize this
because it's the nineties they cracked
me up but in the end I think back and
that's really what makes the movie float
for me cuz the movie for me fell flat I
mean it's exciting when things go pew
pew pew sure what is this the twenty
first movie in the MCU like in terms of
cinematic universe years it's old enough
to get drunk point is we've seen a lot
you got to give us something to connect
with really this movie is one of those
amnesia self-discovery movies or it's a
buddy cop movie or is the
fish-out-of-water movie because she
doesn't really know how earth operates I
feel like all of those elements have
been in other movies but I feel like
other movies have just done them better
yes some entertainment along the way
some chuckles some reveals because there
is mystery in this movie some reveals I
thought were good I was like alright
props that was well done that was good
there is one thing
it's too big I want to say what it is
but
it's one of those oh hey here's how this
happened kind of like how Han Solo got
his blaster kind of moment and it's dumb
they could have done anything and they
did that and it's dumb maybe they did it
for the sake of a joke or irony or
something but I just now its cannon
there's no one doing it whatever I like
some things if she did I guess I like
snarky people because when she's being
snarky I like that but there's this one
arc with this friend I felt nothing I
felt no connection between her and this
friend and I feel like that's because
the movie has to cover a lot of ground
there's a lot of backstory and you don't
get it other than a couple of flashes I
mean in terms of the movie being a
feminist piece they've said it is they
the overlords the studio people brie
Larson and I'm not slandering movie in
saying this I'm just illustrating the
fact this is what it's been said it is
and after watching the movie it's
apparent that that's what it is and
whether or not that's enough for a movie
to float if that's enough for your
entertainment that's up to you for me
it's it's not I think a movie can have a
feminist message but still has to be
interesting it has to have good pacing
good flow and this movie kind of drags
on in parts like I don't get to say this
often but today I get to DC did it
matter fact I would argue gal gadot as
Wonder Woman was more charismatic than
brie Larson as Captain Marvel I mean
Wonder Woman's liked the feminist hero
entertaining movie and she was in fact
powerful I mean I get chills and
goosebumps in that scene where she's
like in the field blocking all the Bulls
with the shield the is awesome most
like that are most effective when the
audience understands that the hero is
vulnerable
maybe not vulnerable to bullets but
maybe emotionally vulnerable you're like
a Wonder Woman Wonder Woman had layers
she was powerful but vulnerable she was
confident but questioned at times she's
a human being a relatable human being
Captain Marvel had no such relatability
for me she starts the movie as a stoic
warrior lady and she ends the movie as a
stoic warrior lady who glows now couple
times she does show something she shows
an emotion but it's always behind this
wall I see that a lot in Hollywood is
like filmmakers think in order to make
someone look strong you need to make
them emotionless
and I just don't agree this movie relies
on what we've been told by people and
we've been told outside the movie that
Captain Marvel is the most powerful MCU
hero ever but the movie never shows us
anything to validate that like does she
take a dying star to the chest I feel
like that's the metric that's what Thor
did that's pretty strong by the end of
this I don't feel like she could take a
dying star to the chest and live I don't
hate this movie it's like there's this
like Star Trek insurrection it's like
the Star Trek insurrection of the MCU
terrible not great has
couple moments I liked has a good
villain just didn't flow as well as I'm
used to in this movie probably would
have been a better time if I were drunk
yeah now it's a party smash the like
button please I feel like I'm gonna get
for that so if you could if you
like this video anyway if you could give
me a like that'd be great that helped
the video alright so Captain Marvel have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]